JEN KING : Hi, I'm Jen King, the
tech lead on the Drive Android
API.
And today I'm going
to show you how
to add drive integration
to your Android app.
This API is a part of
Google Play services, which
means that you can add a small
amount of code to your app
and get the benefits
of these API features
on nearly every Android device
running Gingerbread or higher.
There are a lot of reasons that
Google Drive integration is
great for users.
Their files get automatically
backed up to the cloud,
are accessible on multiple
devices including the web,
and can be viewed and edited
on mobile devices and the web
using Drive-enabled
apps, even when offline.
So let's get started.
I'm going to demonstrate how
to integrate an app with Drive
using our receipt
collector sample app.
This app allows users to take
pictures of their receipts
and store them in Drive
to manage their spending.
In order to use the
Drive Android API,
you first need to register
your app as a Drive app
by creating an entry in
the Developer Console.
The Console will
ask you to specify
the package name of your app and
the fingerprint of your signing
certificate so that the Drive
API can authenticate your app.
Creating a project
ID on the Dev Console
allows you to build
versions of your app
across Android, iOS, and the
web and share a single project
configuration for all of them.
Once your project
is registered, you
can start using
the Drive Android
API by including the
Google Play services
APIs in your application.
Before integrating with Drive,
our app just saves the receipts
to the local file system
on the device, which
means they aren't easily
accessible on other devices.
If I lose or break
my device, the data
might get lost with it.
However, it's easy to
back up these receipts
to Drive using the
Drive Android API.
To do this, we'll
create a new file
with the image bytes
using the Drive API, which
will sync the data
up to the server.
We need to write the receipt
image to a contents object
and create a new Drive
file using this contents.
For now, we'll just
add all the receipts
to the user's root folder,
also called My Drive.
To save the new file, we call
createFile on the folder where
we want to insert the file
and pass in the contents
object containing the data.
The createFile call will return
the Drive ID of the new file.
Receipts will now get
automatically uploaded
to the user's Drive, allowing
users to view and organize them
in the Drive Web UI.
Next, we need to
change our receipt list
to request the list
of receipt files
from the Drive API instead
of the local file system.
To do this, we'll query for all
files in the user's My Drive
folder that are accessible
by the receipts app.
This query uses the local
Drive database rather than
the server, so it will
still work while offline.
The Drive Android API will
automatically sync metadata
for files created
from other devices.
We'll change our
receipt list view
to use data from the
Drive API by changing
the adapter in our list view
to use the metadata buffer
object returned by
the query method.
We use the title field
to generate an entry
for each file on the list.
Last, we need to display the
receipt image and description
when users open
it from the list.
To display the receipt
image, get the Drive file
for the receipt using
DriveApi.getFile,
and open the contents using
DriveFile.openContents.
If the file content is already
available on the device,
the Open File method
will return immediately.
And if not, the
Drive Android API
will fetch the content
from the server for you.
Now, the app functions
just as it did before
with the added
benefit that users
can open all of their receipts
on any Android device,
as well as on the web.
There are three
more cool features
that can help us to make
the user experience better.
Pinning files, the File
Picker UI, and app folders.
First, you can allow your
users to save receipts
for offline use,
or pin the files,
using the Set Pinned API.
This API will ensure that the
file content is on the device
and will keep it up to date.
To surface this
feature to users,
we'll add a Pin button
into our View Receipt
UI, which allows
the user to choose
to keep the file on the device.
Second, we're currently
saving all receipts
to the user's My Drive folder.
But what if they want to
be a little more organized?
We can allow users
to choose which
folder to use for saving their
receipts by launching the Drive
File Picker.
Once the user selects Folder,
we save this preference
to the device.
And every time we
create a new receipt,
we create it in the
selected folder.
Last, it would be a lot
better if this preference were
consistent between
multiple devices.
We could store our
preferences in a file in Drive
just like we do with
receipts, but it
would be better if
we didn't clutter
the user's Drive with
preference files.
Here's where our last
feature comes in.
App folders are a
special type of folder
where you can store
files that only
your app can see and manage.
This folder still uses
the user storage quota,
and they can clear all
of the folder contents
if they want to
stop using your app,
but the files won't
ever get in their way.
So let's recap what
we've achieved.
We took an app that stored
of all of its content
on the local device and added
automatic backups, cross device
file syncing, offline support,
and synced app configuration.
You can add these
features to your app too,
so get started with
the Drive Android API
at
developers.google.com/drive/android.
I'm Jen King, and I can't
wait to see what you come up
with using the
Drive Android API.